[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so... Third wheel, son.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, it sounds like we're all on a, if we can detect Lord Farrowind, we want to save Lord Farrowind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Trying to find Farrowind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you don't see him, but you want to be lowered into the water?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Does the light of the arm kind of lighten the water up?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm looking to see if, in any other residual light, if Lord Fairwind is already up on the rocks a little bit underneath the walkway.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you guys look in the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm looking to make sure, see if the sharks start swimming back or anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You see the sharks start swimming back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sharks coming back!
[SPEAKER_00]: And in fact, in the light, there's a sahagin in the water as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not many, but they're there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shark and sahuagin in the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need to keep moving.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, we got to get to the barrels.
[SPEAKER_01]: We got to get to the barrels.
[SPEAKER_02]: I start yanking on the rope, pulling them back up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm like, yeah, it's that crowded.
[SPEAKER_01]: We all move.
[SPEAKER_01]: Move.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get to the barrels.
[SPEAKER_02]: You need to get barrels you need to put in that water.
[SPEAKER_01]: That'll shake out at least the sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you guys want to gather in the room?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is going to be...
[SPEAKER_03]: Protecting the place where they come in.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm imagining this is barred off and they've got barrels and shit over here.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I'm guessing.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you able to see through that door?
[SPEAKER_03]: It just goes into more cavern.
[SPEAKER_03]: Storage room and locked for all the barrels.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, this probably goes to the cavern.
[SPEAKER_04]: Remember there was a way we could climb down the cliff?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I think Cliff was just basically saying it's like beach slash boat.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, he said there was another entrance from the cliff.
[SPEAKER_04]: You had to climb down it, and there was another entrance from the beach, and that's probably what this is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, from the beach, which is close to probably where the boats come in.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's where they were loaded and stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, go down, crash, crash, because they're going to stage any barrels down on any kind of a landing, so we need to get the barrels open, or one of them, and get that shit in the water.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, throw it in the water so when it's to hog him trying to come down, fucking die.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'll skin their asses.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is the way the water goes?
[SPEAKER_00]: This way?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Beneath that or something?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the cavern keeps going, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: This room is kind of hewn out of the cavern.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So there's rock there, but this continues on to another cavern.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go, go, go.
[SPEAKER_04]: Lay on hands.
[SPEAKER_04]: Give myself another ten back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, let's proceed down towards the... Do you think we should blow the bridge behind us?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah heading towards the ballista.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm in front.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge, what's our... Alright, so the party emerges from that small room out into a huge grotto and this is like...
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, 500 feet across.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, it's a huge cavern, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Big enough for that ship to come in here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Big enough for that ship to come in.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in fact, the way the cavern looks is obviously there's an entrance and I'm doing this roughly this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're up here on like a platform.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's more of that kind of wooden walkway.
[SPEAKER_00]: That goes down to a landing and there are docks right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you show us where the big ballista was and what direction it's pointing?
[SPEAKER_00]: This is where you are and this is where the ballista is.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's pointing that direction.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's obviously a fortification for anybody that tries to get to this area.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do we see anybody down there loading anybody?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, there's no ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are tents.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you see a stack of barrels right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I would say it's maybe like 20 or so.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ballista into the barrels.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not all of them.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, you just throw one in and then shoot it in the water.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or if you can't open it in the cork.
[SPEAKER_03]: You just take the cork off the top and then you throw it in.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need one person to help me man the ballista.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm proficient with crossbows, so you can do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, you're at the end.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're going to help me out.
[SPEAKER_01]: The rest of you fuckers, go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Assault the landing.
[SPEAKER_03]: We don't see anyone down there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, he said there's tents.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't know if there's people down there.
[SPEAKER_01]: If there's nobody down there, if a bunch of people come out of the tents and you're in, like, some death fight on the walkway, we'll launch the bullets out.
[SPEAKER_04]: And how far is this distance from here to there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I'm sure we can, yeah, I mean, like, we could shoot that, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I assume.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, but I mean, spell range.
[SPEAKER_04]: I want to know for spell range.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you say five pounds?
[SPEAKER_00]: The cavern's huge, but I can get you the distance from the landing.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do want to go back and check this room if we're clear.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do want to come back and look in here just to see if there's any more barrels in there.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's probably 200 feet from where the ballista is down to where the dock is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that ballista range?
[SPEAKER_00]: Ballistas have a range of 400 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so it's beyond my spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you two wanted to man the ballista, I could move down the walkway and use my spells, but it's beyond my spell, but I'll stay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You two want to, like, operate the ballista?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're leaving, like, fucking Merry and Pippin together.
[SPEAKER_03]: Easy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'll stay with Merrick, then.
[SPEAKER_01]: The bard's already in front of me.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Goddammit!
[SPEAKER_00]: We're going.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so wait a second.
[SPEAKER_00]: You say, we're all gonna go down this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just push Ty.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go, go, go, go.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know what they're doing behind me, but I'm pushing him, go.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I told Gouge, I say, me and Merrick have the ballista.
[SPEAKER_00]: So some of the two are out, just give him a wave.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, Paul, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess I'm going with them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you start walking down the ledge with them.
[SPEAKER_00]: The three of you stay at the top?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, not three.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think I'm, I guess I'm going with them.
[SPEAKER_06]: How many spells do you have left?
[SPEAKER_06]: I have one spell left.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is it a good one?
[SPEAKER_01]: I hope it's a good one.
[SPEAKER_01]: You better sing your ass off.
[SPEAKER_02]: You hold back and look behind us, make sure nothing's coming up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'll just...
[SPEAKER_02]: Coming up what?
[SPEAKER_02]: From behind.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sahuagin, Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_02]: Back from here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you sure you want to do that?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, if you want to go down and be in combat, you can do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Whatever you want to do, man.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, I should probably stay up.
[SPEAKER_06]: I have my voice for 60 feet.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can use vicious mockery as many times as you need.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, if the bard's staying up, I'm going down.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not staying up with three of us.
[SPEAKER_06]: Those are arguing, we're continuing.
[SPEAKER_06]: Would you be able to see their combat?
[SPEAKER_06]: You would be able to.
[SPEAKER_06]: Would it be within 60 feet?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's 200 feet away.
[SPEAKER_00]: If that's when they got attacked.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you would be able to attack with your bow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Me?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm staying up here for sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: I wouldn't be able to do much.
[SPEAKER_06]: Folsum, you go down.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I'll go down.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, Jude, are you gonna stay up?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, me and him will stay up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You say, yeah, I'm not a bad guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see why you're not in the military.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, the two of you say where you are, and the four of you begin walking down the bank.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I recognize this area of the island?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's there.
[SPEAKER_04]: All four of us are there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll a survival check.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's 20, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, so you two stay back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Me and Merrick stay back by the ballista.
[SPEAKER_01]: 20 ballistics.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we make sure the ballista's loaded.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: We make sure the ballista's loaded, cranked.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've never been here, but it's very similar to what you would see on the map.
[SPEAKER_03]: I have 15 hit points.
[SPEAKER_00]: So yeah, this is there, obviously.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I have not a lot.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, it's only 20 feet to the water.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's my last cure wounds.
[SPEAKER_00]: Definitely, in the water.
[SPEAKER_06]: Can I yell to them?
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Guys, when you get down there, a barrel needs to get in the water immediately.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is swimming with sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they're close enough to the dock where they can come up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, they'll come up and fuck you up.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna use- Wait!
[SPEAKER_01]: Use 20 barrels?
[SPEAKER_01]: Fuckin' shoot one!
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'm not gonna shoot like fuck it.
[SPEAKER_01]: This thing will wipe out like five barrels.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, but he has a bow.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know, is it liquid?
[SPEAKER_03]: Is it sand?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know if this shit is.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like a powder.
[SPEAKER_03]: Here we go.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let's talk one at a time so we can all hear what's going on.
[SPEAKER_05]: What do you say?
[SPEAKER_05]: So you ask what it is?
[SPEAKER_03]: He just said, careful there's a hagen in the- Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm like, shoot a fucking barrel then.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then you ask, is it liquid?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it powder?
[SPEAKER_03]: What is it?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's a powder sand, kinda.
[SPEAKER_01]: You gotta sprinkle it in the water.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need to save as many as we can.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've got the ballista man.
[SPEAKER_01]: If the hagen come out, we'll shoot at it.
[SPEAKER_02]: We got you covered.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just need to open a barrel down there.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll cover you guys.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm gonna use my last cure words on Paul Ribeiro.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, now you're helping us out.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, what do you have a point?
[SPEAKER_06]: What do you have a point?
[SPEAKER_06]: Roll for how many hit points come back?
[SPEAKER_06]: One die eight?
[SPEAKER_06]: One die eight plus any modifiers.
[SPEAKER_06]: Plus your plus four.
[SPEAKER_06]: Plus four, cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: 12 points of damage back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or did you already add that?
[SPEAKER_03]: I already added it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is that one, that extra one I got still going?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's a bard thing?
[SPEAKER_06]: Ten minutes.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, so...
[SPEAKER_06]: When did you give it to him?
[SPEAKER_06]: I gave it to him.
[SPEAKER_06]: I held his ass right here.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's still going.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's warm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so we make sure that we have a ballista loaded.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm ready for any sahuagin that come up in the dock.
[SPEAKER_01]: Try not to hit our own group.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not a siege guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so the party with Tyrus in front, Gouge next, Paul Ribeiro next, and Folsom behind run down the path towards the dock.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I need to get a rag.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was eight.
[SPEAKER_06]: I did four plus four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you have like a crossbow?
[SPEAKER_03]: I have my voice.
You know what we do have?
[SPEAKER_06]: I have a vicious mockery.
[SPEAKER_06]: Vicious mockery.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Within 60 feet.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: The mind's really wetted.
[SPEAKER_03]: I need a pretty good, period.
[SPEAKER_03]: It hurts often on, but hasn't been through, period.
[SPEAKER_03]: I need to change the bandage, period.
[SPEAKER_02]: Isn't that how girls talk about their tampons?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can speak from experience.
[SPEAKER_06]: What?
[SPEAKER_05]: I can speak from experience.
[SPEAKER_05]: Who are you hanging out with?
[SPEAKER_05]: What did you like to know?
[SPEAKER_05]: Not really.
[SPEAKER_05]: The bar gets around.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, dog farted.
[SPEAKER_05]: Obviously, he's not hanging out in the Royal Palace.
[SPEAKER_05]: You gotta quit going to the foreign district, dude.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hey, that's a foreign radio.
[SPEAKER_02]: I took him to Ferbs.
[SPEAKER_05]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, you found me.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll find out my bar.
[SPEAKER_00]: No one knows what it means, but it's provocative.
[SPEAKER_02]: Murmur from my bar.
[SPEAKER_02]: You'll find out what it's like.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shit place.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you found me in there.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was born in the first.
[SPEAKER_03]: Found you in there, grabbed it by the nape of your neck and led you out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright, not the place for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whatever.